today's video has been made possible by
one dream an online learning platform
with thousands of courses lectures and
documentaries stick around until the end
to find out more
[Music]
oh
cryptids are undoubtedly some of my
favorite creatures from folklore having
already covered the likes of the mothman
the jersey devil the chupacabra and the
loch ness monster it's about time we
return to north america home to hundreds
of unique and strange creatures
i cannot think of a better place to
start than with bigfoot a creature that
is said to roam the forests of the
united states and canada
bigfoot is also referred to as sasquatch
and the most common description is as a
large hairy ape-like or humanoid
creature that stands anywhere between 6
to 10 feet tall
the name bigfoot originates from a group
of men working for a logging company out
of california in 1958
during several jobs they noticed heavy
equipment and material being moved
around once they established it was none
of them they assumed it must have been
some kind of practical joke a man called
jerry crew came across a set of 16-inch
footprints that he thought were human
the rest of the workers began to see
these footprints and assumed they
belonged to the mysterious prankster
they started calling this mysterious
figure bigfoot
eventually their story as well as a cast
of the footprint would appear in a local
newspaper and thus the legend of bigfoot
began
mentions and depictions of creatures
similar to bigfoot go back centuries and
can be traced back to several native
american tribes those native to what is
now california carved images of wild and
hairy men that are now compared to the
modern idea of bigfoot
most alleged sightings occur in north
west america but spread across the
entirety of north america especially in
rocky and forest dense areas like the
great lakes region
most of these claims are explained as
hoaxes or large animals such as bears
being mistaken for bigfoot those who
claim to have seen bigfoot describe a
range of varying behavior from throwing
rocks and branches at people to hanging
bones of animals on trees to mark his
territory and of course chasing those
pesky trespassers off said territory the
majority of these sightings happen when
it's dark which naturally makes bigfoot
even harder to identify but has also led
to the idea that he is a nocturnal
creature
stories from indigenous tribes speak of
these figures as something to be feared
but also respected they aren't
malevolent or malicious
we do see this with many stories
surrounding bigfoot it's often him
defending his territory
as opposed to going out of his way to
attack someone
despite all the hysteria the hoaxes the
alleged sightings and the skeptics we
are still no closer to finding bigfoot
but one thing is for sure there is no
shortage of people willing to continue
this search
and who knows
maybe one day they'll find what they're
looking for
we find ourselves back in west virginia
this time taking a look at the devil
dogs also known as the white things and
sheepsquatch
most reported sightings of these
creatures happen around the southern
counties of west virginia
their appearance varies from demonic
dogs to something that is more akin to a
yeti or sasquatch that crawls on all
fours commonly they are described as a
creature the size of a bear with white
fur a long pointed head and saber-like
teeth much like the mothman they are
also thought to have come from the tnt
area in mason county those who claim to
have been attacked say it felt as real
as anything they've experienced before
they felt the fangs and claws tearing
into their flesh but when the attack was
over there were no marks
no blood and nothing to suggest they had
even been attacked in the first place
the first reported sighting of the devil
dogs came in 1973
with a family driving by point pleasant
the seven-year-old boy in the back told
his parents he saw something with thick
white shaggy fur that was about three
foot wide
the family then said the creature
appeared right beside the car floating
in the air following them for several
minutes before disappearing
sightings continued over the years along
the roadside but mostly in heavily
wooded areas
the last recorded encounter was in 2015
when six campers came across something
on top of a hill at around at midnight
shining their torches in its direction
they revealed a creature over nine feet
tall that was charging down the hill the
only thing separating them was a small
river the creature stopped around for
several minutes looking for a way to
cross but when it couldn't find one it
jumped in the river and began to swim
across
the group ran back to their campsite
gathered their belongings and fled they
reported the incident to the locals but
not the authorities for fear of not
being believed as it does sound like a
story made up by someone high on shrooms
in the forest
for the next creature we head to maumee
valley in northern indiana where we find
the beast of busco an enormous snapping
turtle
this story begins in 1898 in a small
indiana town known as chirabusco or
busco for short
a farmer named oscar falk came across a
giant turtle living in the lake on his
farm
he told others in the town but no one
would take him seriously and so he
decided against pursuing the turtle any
further
50 years later two locals reported
seeing a turtle that must have weighed
close to 500 pounds whilst they were out
fishing in what was now known as folk
lake the owner of the farm at the time
had also reported seeing the giant
turtle
the story soon became national news and
groups of people flocked to the town in
hopes of seeing this monster turtle for
a town of just over a thousand people
this had a pretty big impact the amount
of people driving to the farm caused so
much traffic the state police were
called in to offer assistance those who
came to see the turtle were extremely
disappointed and questioned whether it
was just a clever ploy by the then owner
gail harris to drive tourism to the town
and his farm
in an effort to clear his name harris
had most of the lake drained but the
turtle now nicknamed the oscar after the
previous owner was nowhere to be seen
several attempts to find him may have
been unsuccessful but the town still
likes to remember oscar as every june
they hold a festival in his memory
a giant turtle in all honesty isn't that
weird but the same can't be said for the
ohio frog man also known as the loveland
frog and the loveland lizard this
cryptid is described as a four foot tall
frog that has been seen all around
loveland ohio the story began in
1955 when a man walking by the roadside
reported seeing three frog-like men with
webbed hands and feet
this could have been easily brushed off
as just another drunk but the reported
sightings continued whilst driving at 3
30 in the morning a man noticed three
reptilian creatures by the road at first
he thought they were humans in costumes
but then he noticed they had leathery
skin like a frog
it gets stranger because one of them
held up what he called a wand and when
sparks began to shoot out he quickly
drove away
could this wand have been a firework
being held by someone in a costume
possibly but i'd like to believe this
man saw three giant frog wizards
practicing magic on the roadside at 3 am
in the morning
interest in the frogmen peaked once
again when the loveland police
themselves killed an animal that matched
its description in 1972 officer ray
shockey was driving when an animal ran
across his vehicle ahead of him he
described a creature that was between
three to four feet tall and between 50
to 75 pounds he said it was crouched
like a frog and eventually stood up on
two feet to climb over the guard rail
and head back down the river two weeks
later officer mark matthews reported
seeing the same unidentified animal
along the same roadside matthews pulled
out his rifle and shot the animal dead
upon examining the corpse he identified
it as a large iguana with a missing tail
which is why both men struggled to
identify it in the first place
stories surrounding the loveland frog
are extremely weird even for a cryptid
we are going back to west virginia and
the town of flatwoods in braxton county
for our last cryptid
the flatwoods monster also known as the
braxton county monster
this cryptid is said to be ten feet tall
and four feet wide it has a red face a
pointed hood and a dark metallic body it
was first seen in 1952
by three young boys who witnessed a
bright object fly across the sky and
crash on the land of a local farmer they
told a woman named kathleen may what
they had seen she and three of the local
boys traveled to the farm to see if the
story was true they came to the top of
the hill where the boys said the object
had landed and ahead of them was a
pulsating red light
when they pointed their flashlights in
its direction they saw a tall man with a
round face and a pointed hood
kathleen describes the monster as having
small claw-like hands a pointed hood and
a head that resembles the ace of spades
one of the boys said its eyes emitted a
green light and had a dark green body
after a few seconds the creature began
to move it made a hissing sound as it
glided towards them
as it got closer all of them recall a
pungent smell
a thick mist that burnt their eyes and
nose
they all panicked and ran away before
they could see the creature up close
the sheriff and his deputy had been
investigating reports of an aircraft
that had crashed but when they visited
the area the morning after they couldn't
see or smell anything
there were several investigations
carried out and what happened that night
has been explained in numerous ways
the bright light across the sky was most
likely a meteor
the pulsating red light could have been
an aircraft hazard beacon
and the creature with glowing eyes and
small claws could have just been an owl
this still hasn't stopped people from
claiming they've seen the flatwoods
monster as well as experiencing the
burning smell for themselves
if you've enjoyed this video and you'd
like to see more stories of cryptids
from north america and the rest of the
world then let me know in the comment
section
as we mentioned earlier today's video
has been sponsored by one dream you may
have heard me talk about the great
courses plus before while they've now
teamed up to create one dream an even
bigger better and immersive educational
experience
one dream aims to answer questions you
never even knew needed asking they have
all the same great courses plus content
but with even more of a selection to
choose from now
along with courses and lectures there
are long and short form videos tutorials
how to's and travelogues as well as a
host of interesting and engaging
documentaries
with halloween rapidly approaching i
found myself watching the three-part
series monsters within which covers the
psychology behind why horror movies are
so popular it also takes a look at
victorian horror novels such as dorian
gray and dr jekyll and their influence
on the genre
it's a great watch for anyone who enjoys
horror
if you'd like to try one dream for
yourself then visit
onedream.com
mythology to start your free trial today
[Music]
you